hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde ihr seht schon Sandra und
ich spielen heute die Sims 4 weißt du
warum wir das heute spielen ja weil die
Sims 4 jetzt kostenlos ist das stimmt
meine lieben Freunde seit einigen Tagen
gibt es die Sims 4 kostenlos für PS4 PS5
Xbox one Xbox series PC also holt euch
noch heute das kostenlose Basisspiel
[Musik]
und da die Sims 4 ab jetzt kostenlos
verfügbar ist haben wir das ganze sich
als anders genommen um mal wieder Sims 4
zu zocken Fehler stellen wir zuerst mich
oder dich dich okay das bist ja quasi
schon einfach du ne mit Sport Outfit
hier immer unterwegs
stell mich wie du denkst wie ich aussehe
ich erstelle dich und du erstellst mich
[Musik]
21 stellen
mein Bruder
du bist schon alt Erwachsener du bist
fast 30
[Musik]
ich habe doch nicht solche Arme
hallo
boah du siehst so fresh aus Mann mach
mich ein bisschen breiter ich bin nicht
so wie du möchtest nein nein
Luca die Nase hast du leider ja so du
hast ja wie total u-formiges Gesicht
so siehst du aus ja wir haben Luca
erstellt
du könntest auch hören weibliche
[Musik]
Oma
ich habe so vergessen wie viel Spaß das
macht und ihr könnt diesen Spaß ganz
einfach zu Hause haben den Sims 4 ist
kostenlos wollen wir nach Urlaub Krieg
ziehen Oasis springst new quest oder
bründle und Bay spricht brendelten Bayer
meisten an okay wusstest du dass es Sims
eigentlich schon seit 22 Jahren gibt
fast so alt wie ich crazy ne ist halt
auch eine der bekanntesten
pc-spielereien aller Zeiten ja also für
mich ist also ich glaube Sims war das
erste Spiel was ich damals auf dem PC
gespielt habe Auswählen eines
Grundstücks
3000 Schwanzspitze
[Musik]
das Haus Schwanzspitze
ich habe gerade mir das wirklich
bildlich vorgestellt und das war nicht
gut
nee wir brauchen kein Einsteiger aus wir
bauen uns ein oder naja deshalb
Notebooks und das krasse alles wie
verdammt noch mal viele Möglichkeiten
was nicht nur bei der
Charaktererstellung bei der
sim-erstellung hier generell
diese Musik ist auch so Nostalgie
also das würden wir auf Geiseln echt gar
keinen Fall machen
das ist ja falsch du willst ja niemals
gehen du willst ein E-Scooter nehmen
ja wir sehen uns jetzt einen Trick
zeigen
junge
was ist falsch mit dieser Frau wir
können jetzt allerdings hier oben in den
Baumodus switchen und haben jetzt die
Möglichkeit uns hier ein bisschen um zu
gucken und ein Haus zu bauen deswegen
würde ich sagen wir bauen uns erstmal so
einen kleinen Raum ja jetzt habe ich
eingesperrt
also ich will auf jeden Fall ein Bett
zum Chillen haben ich brauche auf jeden
Fall auch ein Kleiderschrank wir machen
jetzt erstmal ein Klo okay dass das
wichtigste ja schön
wir brauchen Fenster ja stimmt damit man
deine Scheiße nicht riechen muss aber
wir Schlafzimmer teilen mit Hochbett
gibt's sogar Luca 1300
wirklich Knast zu machen komm mach mal
so ein Teppich da noch rein
er ist total schön
ich finde den habe ich immer noch am
besten aber die Zeitung
[Musik]
luca ist aber irgendwie das ist ein
Vorhänge und kein Fenster ne kann es
sein dass du dumm bist
scheiße
Fernseher gekauft gut mein Fehler wir
brauchen auf jeden Fall so eine Bank vor
der so eine Veranda Bank weiß so eine
Schaukel dass man da chillen kann auf
der rechten dürfen nur meine Freunde
sitzen auf der linken deine erstmal
brauchen wir jetzt eine dicke Couch
[Musik]
es sieht so gruselig aus
ja und sieht noch gruseliger aus jetzt
alter Schwede
meine Seite dann kannst du aber kein
Fernsehen gucken egal warte dann machen
wir so
[Applaus]
eins will ich nicht wir blenden euch
jetzt noch eine ganz schnelle timelapse
ein wie wir einmal kurz den Rest von
unserer Bude hier fertig bauen
[Musik]
ich wünsche wir hatten so viel Geld dass
wir so richtig schöne Bahnen stellen
könnten aber klappbar kein Platz bei uns
im Haus wir können das ja machen das
Genießen motherload Cheat aber ich will
es eigentlich selber erreichen ich
glaube jeder kennt diesen motherlode
Cheat ne von damals wurde dir unendlich
Geld holen konntest so ein bisschen
Kunst brauchen wir das ist ein bisschen
schön ist
okay wir haben wirklich nur noch fünf
Dollar
wir sind fertig wir haben keine einzigen
Cent mehr aber das ist unser Haus Leute
wir haben hier unsere Zahl vier Platz im
Wohnbereich ja wir haben hier unser
Schlafzimmer wir haben genügend
Rauchmelder für Sandra falls Sie beim
Schlafen machen sollte wir haben unsere
Küche ne mit irgendwie Fenstern die wir
nicht so ganz gut angeordnet haben wir
haben dJ Antoine hier hängen das andere
nicht auf dem Sofa und hier vorne unser
Wohnzimmer mit äh Fernseher etc jetzt
würde ich allerdings sagen lernen wir
zum Ende des Videos noch mal ganz kurz
unser Nachbarn kennen wir bekommen
Besuch wir bekommen Besuch
Begrüßungskomitee kommt an aber die will
dich kennenlernen die will ich mich
kennenlernen aber komischerweise gehe
ich da nicht Hallo Ich hallo sagen hey
habe ich mich jetzt umgezogen
du hast dich nicht schick gemacht am
Fernsehen gucken
ich finde unser Haus gar nicht mal so
schlimm Luca Alter sieht aus wie
ich schwöre dir mit noch so ein paar
Deko Sachen Alter ist Boden und Wände
komm wir machen einmal mother Lotion
Steuerung shift 10 motherlode zack 50
was was
wer ist man echt nehmen so mit dem
Millionär von daher können wir uns jetzt
zumindest noch mal ganz kurz Fußboden
und Wände
zwei Stunden später passt passt
[Musik]
das hier ist unser Haus die
Schwanzspitze ich werde mir auf jeden
Fall noch mal ganz kurz hier in Gold
klären zum Abschluss des Videos bitte
noch mal kurz geflirtet
boah was bist du denn für ein Mensch du
stellst dich nicht mehr persönlich vor
sondern sie soll dahin kommen oder wie
was machen die denn jetzt reden jetzt
oder nicht ja
[Musik]
nein nein nein
Luca
lösch meine Nummer
du machst doch nicht ernst
[Musik]
gesagt
ich kann nicht mehr an der Stelle würden
sagen und ich das heutige Video jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
Freunde Dankeschön an die Sims 4 die das
heutige Video hier tatkräftig
unterstützt haben und das auf jeden Fall
ultra viel Spaß gemacht es gibt so viele
Möglichkeiten vor allem auch dadurch
dass das Spiel jetzt kostenlos ist haben
auch noch mehr Leute die Möglichkeit
jetzt diese Spiele zu spielen also ladet
euch jetzt runter ihr findet Link unten
in der Videobeschreibung die haben auch
einen riesig geilen Livestream gemacht
die Tage wo sonst alle vorgestellt haben
aber was machst du da ja ich versuche
dir gerade eine Freundin zu klären
gucken wir uns vielleicht im nächsten
Part an wenn ihr Bock habt auf den
nächsten Part von Sims mit Sandra und
Luca dann lasst einen Daumen hoch unter
diesem Video hier da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos nichts verpassen schreibt immer
unten in die Kommentare welcher Sims 4
Spielertyp ihr seid
[Gelächter]
ja das war gerade der handschocker der
bei dir nicht geklappt hat es lebe das
Chaos
Luca scheint sich am Schrecken und der
Wut anderer zu ergat ergötzen ist nun
der Zeitpunkt gekommen zuzugeben dass er
Unfug mag okay kümmern wir uns
vielleicht im nächsten Video darum
schreibt's in die Kommentare wenn wir
weitermachen sollen wir sehen uns haut
rein ciao